With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver. And with Instacart's in-store prices at select stores, you can do more this winter without paying more. So double down on your shortbread production without upping the price. Add more chilies to your chili without the added sting. Go completely ham on candy DMs and celebrate the season of being extra without paying extra. So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Instacart. Groceries that over-deliver.
Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Welcome to our second drink of Money Part 1. Oh, I loved this episode. Angela, I remember we reached out to Paul Lieberstein about this one. He wrote and directed it. He had such good stuff to share. So many good details. Well, look, I want to kick off the second drink with a deleted Michael talking head.
We did not discuss this in our first rewatch. Oh. Let me set it up for you. Okay. So remember how Jan is bringing in fabrics for Michael. to look at. Yes, she's spending like all his money on redecorating. The condo, yes. Okay. Well, Michael has a talking head. It's in the kitchen. He's alone. And he shares that he has a friend who actually loves interior design. And I thought you should hear who he's talking about.
You know who loves interior design? My friend, Todd Packer, he, uh, he is always asking if Jan's carpet matches or drapes. He, now, although he says that he prefers it when there is no carpet, which doesn't make sense because I've been to his apartment and there is shag carpeting all over the place. So I guess people's design sensibilities change. Okay. They needed to cut this.
Can I tell you why? Yeah. Because in the pilot, isn't it the pilot? Todd Packer calls and says, ask her if the carpet matches the draughts. And Michael's like, Like Michael clear on it. He knows what that phrase means.
But in this talking head, he has no clue. No, he's clueless. No clue. I mean, Todd Packer has shag carpeting. Well, that's an insight. Yeah, it is. Kind of perfect, though, also. For sure.
He probably also has a waterbed or a like a round bed. He has a waterbed, yes. He definitely has a mirror on the ceiling, too. Oh. Well, moving on, I have a question from Ruth Ann C about this episode. She says, every time I watch this episode, it strikes me how surprised Pam is to see the outhouse at Shrewt Farms. But haven't they been there for hours at that point? Wouldn't Pam have had to go to the bathroom before then?
I feel like that's a long time to not go pee. Anyone else, Jenna, Angela. Agree. You agree? I mean, I feel like getting to Shrewt Farms is probably a little bit of a drive, right? It's not like in Scranton. It's on the outskirts. And by the time I got there, the first thing I'd have to do is go pee.
when I arrived. Well, let me say that when we introduce the idea of shrewd farms, it is in season two. You know, that's the one where Michael buys his condo and Dwight talks about owning shrewd farms. And he says, there's only one bathroom and it's under the porch. That's what he says. So I'm wondering if Pam knows this information about the lack of bathrooms, maybe she made Jim stop before they got to shrewp farms. somewhere. Maybe she peed in a field. I don't know. Okay. Okay. So I think maybe she hasn't needed a bathroom for hours. Well, I'm with Ruth Ann. I'm wondering what's up. Well, also in this breakdown,
we discuss how cute Pam's outfit is that she's sleeping in. And we started discussing the various things people can sleep in. And I asked, does anybody actually sleep in like a silky slip nightgown like you see in the movies all the time? Yeah. If I remember, you sort of put out a call to action. Like, tell me, if you do this, will you tell me? We got a fan meal flirty. Jana, Kristen, Becca, Christina, and many more said that they do sleep in silk nighties. In fact, Becca said, I do have nightgowns in my sleepwear rotation. They are mostly designated for summertime. They are soft and comfortable. And a few other folks said that they're cooler to sleep in, and that's why they like them. Well, if they're cooler to sleep in, we might should start
trying it. I mean, as women of a certain age with certain kind of hot slashes at night, it might be silk 90 time. Okay, our second fan mail flurry was about the poster in Dwight's room. So if you remember, it's a very super quick cutaway, and I became obsessed with it. I zoomed in on it, you know, like I took a picture of the screen, right? And I had a theory, because it's a little blurry. Okay. I thought, ooh, this is a little foreshadowing nugget. It's got to, to be Motley Crew, right? Yes, I remember. Dwight loves Motley crew. But, lady, many people wrote in to tell me. Very nicely, by the way, Michelle, Stephen, Emily, Morgan, Nate, Tara, Molly, and Moore said, Angela, it is a Van Halen poster. Oh. Tara, I want to thank you because you
did write. But you know what, Angela, it was a nice theory. So thank you for that. Listen, these are in the same world. Motley Crew, Van Halen. They're adjacent. They're adjacent. You were on the right track. Mm-hmm. Well, we also got a great background catch by Danny. Danny pointed out that the sofa that Jim and Pam are sitting on when they arrived at Shrewt Farms, it has a very nice nod to Scranton. There is a Scranton PA throw blanket. It's stitched across the front. It says Scranton, go to nine minutes, 12 seconds. It's draped over the back of the sofa and get this. What? Ben L. from Pittsburgh doubled down on this catch and said the same blanket comes back in where. women's appreciation when the fellows go hang out in the ladies' bathroom. We had clearly one Scranton, Pennsylvania blanket. Mm-hmm. Well, I love that they just kept repurposing it. Those are great catches.
Very good. I mean, the same blanket at Shrewp Farms and the women's restroom. Wow, that's attention to detail. Well, lastly, I went into our candy bag alts for this episode, and there were so many fun Michael talking heads. I thought I'd share two alts, okay? Remember when Michael shares that he and Jan are down to only. one car. And, you know, they did this to save money. But then, of course, Jan wanted a Porsche.
So she's driving a Porsche, but they only have one car. Well, there were two alts for this talking head and they cracked me up. Jan and I are sharing a car now. I love the seepering. But, you know, the ozone layers are peeling. The ice hats are melting. And no owls have been spotted in a long time. And the other birds. Oh. Lady. What? The ice hats are melting. Oh, it's a mangled. Michael mangled word. It's ice caps. Okay. The next one is, Jan and I are sharing a car now.
The lease got up on the Sebring and we could have gotten two so-so cars or one really nice car. Our three really crappy cars are zero really, really great ones or a fleet of mopeds. But Jan shot that down. Oh, okay. This is how he money manages. Yes. He's going to trade in the Sebring and get a fleet of mopeds. Or three crappy cars.
Yeah. All right. Well, I hope you enjoyed our little extra tidbits. And now here is our second drink of money part one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hi, everybody. Hey there. You guys, I'm so excited to be here today.
Not that I'm not always excited, but I don't know. I just really enjoyed this episode. It cracked me up. I liked it too. I, it was a surprise to me. I had kind of a little bit forgotten about this one. Yeah, I hadn't seen this in a good while. So it was just fun to be an audience.
Well, let's tell everyone what we're talking about today. it is Money Part 1, which is Season 4, Episode 7, written by Paul Lieberstein and directed by Paul Lieberstein. Yes. Should I hit you with a summary? I was hoping you would. I knew you were. I knew you wouldn't let it go by without a summary.
A great summary? I would never. An amazing summary by me? I'm hoping for a summary and three fast facts. I mean, come on. Oh, lady, you're going to be happy. Good. I'm going to sip my tea and listen and only judge a little.
Go for it. What? All right, here we go. Here's a summary. Michael is forced to confront his money woes as Jan renovates his condo. He has to take a second job as a telemarketer. Pam and Jim spend a night at Dwight's family beet farm, which he is now running as a bed and breakfast. Kelly and Daryl work on their relationship, and Andy tries to woo Angela.
Thank you. Any judgments? Any judgments there? No. No. No. Oh. Not yet. Good so far. All right. Well, fast fact number one. Now I mentioned that this episode was written by Paul and directed by Paul. But this was actually the first episode directed by Paul Lieberstein. Ah. Yeah. So he will go on to direct many more, but this was his office directorial debut. Oh, gee. Yeah. So I reached out to him because I was like, I mean, he wrote it. He directed it. Let's hear from him. Yeah. And he told me that he wrote this episode while he was on vacation in Russia. What? Yeah. I didn't know he'd ever vacation in Russia. Paul would have been a really interesting thing to banter about while we were on set waiting for lights to go up and stuff. He's holding back. I did know he'd been to Russia. Oh. There you go. How was it? Was it great? It was great. He had a great, great time. Well, he said that he was so excited to be able to write and direct this episode because it featured the first visit to Dwight's farmhouse at Shrewt Farms.
Because we've been there. We saw the barn in the initiation and all that. But he got to completely invent Dwight's home and what it looked like and all of that stuff. and he said that he got the idea for Dwight to run a bed and breakfast during a trip to Italy a couple years before. He is a world traveler. He's well traveled. Yes. So while he was in Italy, he had seen a bunch of signs for this farm B&B stay. You go stay on people's farms in Italy. Sounds amazing. I just want Paul to know if you're listening, Paul, you don't have to go all the way to Italy for that. You can have a farm B&B right here. I'm sure like my family farm in Texas would take you in. I would love to have a farm B&B experience at your parents' farm. I would love that so much. I would love to get up in the morning and go check on the cows with you. Oh,
lady, you're speaking my language. Well, Paul just said he loved imagining Dwight as a proprietor of a bed-and-break and he also told me he did so much to prepare for this episode. He really like over-prepared because it was just a really big deal to him and he wanted it to be full of so many details. And it was. Oh, yes. There's so many cool details and we're going to point them out to you as they come up. Definitely. All right, fast fact number two is a location breakdown. I knew this was coming. The Shrut Farm's location breakdown. I have been to this farm many times. Let's hear what you got. So we mentioned before that we shot shrewd farms on the Disney ranch in Santa Clarita, California. We went back for this episode, and this time we used the Olivia's house
location, that is the farmhouse that we transformed into Dwight's B&B. Yes, you guys should know this is a vast property, and they have different areas where they film. So they have the barn, right, where you saw the initiation. And then they have little houses and different areas that you can use to create sort of this rustic look for TV and film.
But these houses, they're just shells. There's nothing in them. Nothing. They're just like exterior shell walls. The walls are not insulated. So it got very, very cold at night. Any of the night scenes,
we were freezing. Freezing and drafty and everything is a little bit dusty. Like if you sit on something, like a little cloud of like, poof, yeah, it kind of comes in. out of it. And our set designers had to go in and they had to meticulously decorate every single
room. Every item you see we put there. That's right. That's right. I have a feeling they went in first and cleaned and then decorated. Why is my memory of Shrewp Farms so dusty? Well, I remember sneezing a lot. It's dusty. It's old. It's run down. You wouldn't want to lean against the wall. I'll just say that. No. You might go right through it. You might. Now, we have another location in this episode. Michael takes a job as a telemarketer. And I asked Kentapedia about this location. The exterior, when you see him walking into the building, we shot that in Van Nuys.
That was near our studio. But the inside of the building, we shot on the 10th floor of the L.A. Times building in downtown L.A. Now, this shocked me. This shocked me because this building is stunning. stunning. It housed the LA Times until 2017. It was designed by this man named Gordon B. Kaufman in the Art Deco style in the 1930s. It won a gold medal at the 1937 Paris Exposition. And it's just, it's so weird to me that this very, like, ordinary telemarketing office is housed inside of this gorgeous piece of architecture. I know. That is so wild because we don't do that building justice at all. We make it look just like any cubicle office anywhere, right? Yeah. Well, I shot a commercial in my 20s in downtown L.A. And I was really stunned because it was a gorgeous building and we were shooting on like the 12th floor.
And then they had like craft and service on a different floor. You know, they used a few floors. And it was like three floors in a row with no people, no one. Wow. So I think there are, like sort of buildings downtown that have just a lot of vacancy. Yeah, there must be. I know. It was really eerie because we were filming at night and it was like a dark corridor. I was like, ooh. Well, I visited the LA Times back in college as part of a film and television summer workshop
that was coordinated by UCLA. And we got to go in and see how they make newspapers. And I remember the lobby. It has this great big globe. and I have all these pictures. It was just amazing. I would love that. I would sign up for that. Yeah. I mean, you know, I love a tour. We would sign up for almost any tour, I feel like. We would. I mean, I feel like we could do a podcast where it's just you and I taking tours and talking about today we went to the peanut factory. Oh, lady, that's a brilliant idea. We have to do that. We travel and go on tours and then tell people about the tour we went on.
I mean, selfishly, I want to do that. That sounds great. Okay. Okay, well, speaking of travel, fast fact number three, trip advisor features very heavily in this episode. Yes. And I want you guys to know, we really did create a page on the real trip advisor for Shrut Farms. And our producers made two profiles and gave two reviews. So you could go on after watching the episode and see these two reviews and see these two reviews
and see the page, we hear one of them in the episode. That's the one from Jim and Pam, and their profile name was J and P2. Mm-hmm. But the other one that you don't hear in the episode, Angela, was from Sprinkles Mom. I know.
And it's a really negative review. It's very negative. Did you find it too? I did. It says, stay away. Propriator is crazy. Oh my gosh. You have to read it.
You have to read it. Okay. It says, I have to warn people about the proprietor of Shrewt Farms. He may portray himself as a gentleman farmer, but he is not what he seems. He killed my cat sprinkles. Who knows what he might do to you or your loved ones? Oh. So the profiles are no longer there, and those reviews are no longer there, but Shrewt Farms is still a page on TripAdvisor.
It has over 1,300 reviews, and it has four stars. I went on the Shrewp Farms TripAdvisor page, and I want you guys to know, it's got a little write-up, it's got a photo. This is something that cracked me up. It says, here are the languages spoken at Shrewp Farms. Are you ready? I'm ready. Now, we know this is just Dwight and Moes, but here are the languages spoken. Okay.
Azarbanji, Bosnian, Burmese, Hebrew, Hindi, Hungarian, Icelandic, Portuguese, oddly not on the list is German. and Dwight answers the phone, Guten Tog. Uh-huh. So, TripAdvisor, you might want to update that. And TripAdvisor's like, guys, this is real. We just agreed to do it. And then the other thing I thought was kind of cool about this, and it's a little bit of a callback.
This was also a task in the Dunder Mifflin Infinity online game. Posting review of Shrewp Farms was part of Dunder Mifflin Infinity's game on their website. That is so cool. And you can still post, as Jenna said, your review today, and I just read one as recent as December 2020. Someone made up a review. Now, I read one, Angela, and I wasn't sure if it was real or not. Oh, yeah?
But a person wrote, guys, this place is not real. I drove all the way there, and there is nothing there, and I was very disappointed. Oh, no. And I was like, wait, wait, did this person really drive to this weird remote location in Pennsylvania, hoping to find fruit farms? You've got to know there's at least one person, right, that doesn't know that it was part of the show and just is wanting to go see it, right?
Yeah. Oh, sorry person who drove there. Sorry, buddy. Well, that's all I got, lady. Well, I thought those were fantastic fast facts. No judgey. No judgey, lady. Oh, I get a no judgey.
A no judgey for you today. That is high praise. Well, before we go to break, we have some great news to share with you guys. It's very exciting. I'm very excited. I'm very excited. Thanks to the Office Ladies fans.
We won IHeart Radio's podcast of the year. Podcast of the year, guys. Woo! On the year. Thank you so much for voting for us. You really have no idea how excited we are about this. We are very, very proud. I mean, lady, we put our heart into this podcast every week.
We do. And I am going to cherish this. a word and put it in a very prominent spot. I'm going to make people pass by it and ask me what it is whenever they come to my house. Oh. I'm going to be super braggy about it and I'm not going to apologize. No, you are not. This just means the world to us. You know, we love this show. We love rewatching it. We love the community that has come here to do this journey with us. And we get to work with our best friend. You guys, it's such a blessing. I am so thankful. I have such a gratitude. I already know where I'm putting mine. I'm putting mine right between my tight-ass
Dundee Award and my She's Kind of a Bitch Award. Those are my two Dundies and it's going right in between them. Well, you're going to trip over mine when you walk through my door. That's where mine's going. It's going on the floor. Right in front of my door so that everyone has to say what's that as they walk into my house. So there you go. It's going to be a really weird spot. Thank you guys so much. It really means a lot. Yeah. Thank you. All right. We'll take a break and we'll be back in just a moment. Okay, so we are back and this scene starts with Michael walking in and he just throws his coat on Pam. And I know it's what you're all here for, but at one second, there's a fantastic shot. Of the plant at Front Reception, tell us all about it.
Okay, it's got an orange pot, and I'm very curious what kind of plant this is. It's got very skinny stems and then kind of wispy, fluffy leaves. What kind of plan is that? My plant people hit me up, I want to know. Well, when I spoke with Steve, our set decorator, he told me that most of the plants that he put at reception were of the vine variety because they did not flower and they stayed pretty consistent for a whole week. Well, I am familiar with the vine plants, and I don't know what this one is. So our Beasley botanical experts out there, hit me up. Let me know what kind of plant that is.
It's at one second. Thank you. Well, this whole cold open is very funny. We find out from Pam in a talking head that Michael has been watching the movie The Devil Wares Prada. But he doesn't watch it all at once. He watches it in little clips. He's a big Merrill Street fan.
So he's clearly identified with her character, and now he is treating Pam the way Merrill Street treats her employees in the film. It cracks me up that he watches it in little clips because if you really look at the scene, you can tell. Because he clearly just sees the part where she goes, steak, give me a steak, you know? So he'll just come out and sort of like just regurgitate what he just watched in like 10 seconds. Well, we had a fan question about this from Amy S. Louise M. Ln. P. and Hannah C. Was John Krasinski with Emily Blunt yet when Michael does these references to the Devil Where's Prada or was it just a coincidence?
It was a coincidence, you guys. I watched this with my daughter and Isabel said, Mom, Devil Wears Prada. Isn't that John's wife? Yeah. Well, listen, this is not the only coincidence and it brings up a a very interesting set of trivia that I have called Six Degrees of Devil Wears Prada. Oh, I am in it.
Let's hear it. The Office cast has a lot of connections to the cast of the Devil Wers Prada. Do you want to hear them? Yes, because I can only think of two. Okay, go. All right, well, we know that John Krasinski will marry Emily Blunt.
Mm-hmm. Steve Karell will go on after this episode to star in Get Smart with Anne Hathaway. Ah. Rain Wilson was in entourage with Adrian Grenier. Oh, that's a good one. Rich Summer, who was also in Devil Wears Prada, will later appear on the office as Pam's art school friend.
And listen to this one. The movie The Devil Wears Prada was based on a book written by Lauren Weisberger, and she's from Scranton. What? Yeah. Angela, you and I will eventually fake laugh at an award show with Meryl Streep. We will.
I feel like that counts. She will have no idea and does not remember that moment, but we did walk up to her fake laughing. And finally, this one's a little bit of a stretch, but Stanley Tucci will marry Emily Blunt's sister
in real life. That's the other one I was thinking of. I love that, by the way, that that's a stretch, but us laughing adjacent to Meryl Streep is not a stretch. Okay. I want you guys to
to know, though, a few months ago, this video went viral of Stanley Tucci making a cocktail. It is fantastic. I highly recommend you watch it start to finish. He just seems really cool. It's like, I want to hang out with Stanley Tucci in his kitchen. Yes, I want to sit on a stool in his kitchen while he makes me a cocktail. Yes, everyone does. Stanley Tucci, you heard that. So you're going to have two uninvited guests at some point. We'll be over soon. So this cold open ends with a Pam talking head. That is really funny. And Jenna, I want you to check out the bloopers because you and Paul Lieberstein. You can hear him laughing off camera. The two of you could not get through this talking head. About million dollar baby, you kept cracking up. Yes, when Pam has to realize
that Michael is going to kill her, we couldn't get through it. We couldn't get through it. I couldn't hold it long enough afterwards without laughing. Well, it's hilarious and there's fun bloopers. You can check it out. Well, this episode opened. with Michael and Jan. Jan's in another juicy couture track suit. And it's all she wears now. And yeah, absolutely. And they're picking out fabric for the condo.
They're doing some redecorating. Yeah, there's a whole runner in deleted scenes where she comes in with this box of all this sort of fabric and curtain and all this kind of like samples. And Michael is just avoiding going into his office to talk to her. He like starts talking to Phyllis out of nowhere and Stanley and they're like, what are you doing? Jan's waiting for you. Well, he has a talking head where he explains why he might be avoiding things because money is really tight.
Jan is insisting that they spend all this money redecorating the condo. But you know, at the end of his life, when he's sitting on his yacht, he's not going to be thinking about money. He's going to be thinking about how many friends he has and his children and his comedy albums. And by the way, he has a yacht, so he probably did pretty well, money-wise. I thought that was so funny. Well, Jenna, as I remember, you have some very strong feelings on yachts and yacht ownership. I do. I don't get it. There was this time when I felt like every time I opened Instagram, every celebrity was like yachting. They were getting on a yacht. And I was like, what is this world? I don't get it.
This yachting vacation world. You're cooped up in a small space on water. I have to imagine you get seasick. And there's a crew right on top of you. Like, I like privacy when I'm on vacation. I don't, I mean, listen, that's a whole other thing that I have. And I think it's because I spent so much time in the service industry being a caterer or whatever. You know, people don't see you when you're a caterer or something, when you're bringing them
the drinks and the hors d'oeuvres. But newsflash, we can actually hear you and see you and everything you're doing. And I can't tell you how many, like, fancy Hollywood parties I catered. I observed so much stuff. People just act like you're invisible. I wouldn't be able to relax on a yacht. I wouldn't be able to relax because I would know that they're watching me. They're listening. I love it. How do these celebrities behave this way on yachts? How are they relaxed? I don't get it. I don't get it. You're pivot about yachting.
Like, I thought, I thought we're going to talk about how it seems wasteful to spend that much money on a boat, but you're like, but also they're watching you. They're watching you. No, it is also, I don't get that part. But ultimately, I think what it is is that I like cities and museums and I like walking on my vacations. I'm not a, I'm not like a sit on a boat and take selfies person. Like, that doesn't, no, that's not for me. I love a boat. I love the ocean.
I love getting out on the ocean, but I don't need to vacation in the boat. Do you know what I mean? Like, I like to be on land, but then take the boat places like adventures. Yes, like you would want to go diving or snorkeling. Yes, yes. But then return to land for the sleeping part. Yes, and the hanging out part and the eating and all that. Yeah.
Well, we're not yachters. We've proved that. You know what you're not going to hear on office ladies? An ad for yachting. You know what else you're not going to hear? Oh my God. I was on the most fabulous yacht. Oh my God.
Cut to two years from now when like we're yachting. And we're on a yacht. That's what happens in the universe. You put something out there and you're like, I would never. And then all of a sudden the universe is like jokes on you. You're a yachter. We get invited to tour the. factory where they make yachts and we love them and they take us out on one and then we take a
selfie on a yacht. Listen, I would love a yacht factory tour. I know, I would too. So now we're at Jim and Dwight's desk pod and Jim overhears Dwight taking what sounds like a reservation for a bed and breakfast. And Jim's like, what, what, what's happening? It's so funny, Jim is clearly on hold with someone or has just made a call and he hangs up so he can better focus on Dwight's phone call. Yeah, it's really good. And for our background catchers, there is a great shot of Dwight's computer screen and it just looks like a paper order. So way to go props. You can't see what Rain was actually surfing on the internet. I have a couple of other background catches here at three minutes, 30 seconds in the background at reception. I am smiling at Randall our camera operator.
Oh. I didn't realize we had started rolling. Oh, that's so cute. So you can see me share a moment with Randall and then quickly get into character. Also in the background on Creed's computer, he is playing an epic game of solitaire. That sounds about right. Mm-hmm. Well, Dwight has this talking head about agro-tourism, and it's more than just a B&B.
It's about people visiting a farm and you give them a bed, and it's like a whole experience. And Pam calls to sort of make a phone. fake reservation, but ends up like booking a trip to Shroup Farms. Yeah. It's going to be Jim and Pam's first night away together. Okay. I love that, actually. I think that's super sweet.
Well, it's definitely like a weekend they'll never forget. Michael has a talking head where explains they used to have two cars, but they traded them in. Now they just have one, and the new car is a Porsche for Jan. Yeah. I mean, Jan is just dismantling his whole life. And when he says, I need the car tonight, she's like, for your improv, can't you just improv driving there or take the bus? Like, she doesn't even know where he's going or what he's doing. She has no idea the big hole financially that she's creating and how he is scrambling. Yeah, I know. It's very sad. It made me sad. Well, we had a fan catch here from Matthew L. Colby Shannon, Joseph Stevens, Catherine A. and McKenna H., among others, who said, Michael says that they traded in both of their cars to buy a Porsche for Jan, but wasn't Michael Sebring a company lease? How would he have traded it in?
Hmm, good catch. Maybe if you don't take the company car, you get some sort of cash credit and he used that for the Porsche. That sounds like a good theory. Do we like that? I made that up just now. I like it very much. Okay. Well, now, lady, we've got this great scene of you and Dwight in the parking lot.
You're getting some of your belongings back. Yes. Dwight gives Angela her cardigan, her sleeping cardigan, her sleep apnea mask. And then Angela asks, well, where's my chair figurine? And Dwight says, I don't know what you're talking about. You, you know, you didn't leave it there. I looked all over. I've scrubbed the room of your memory.
And she's like, huh, fine. Well, I had a few questions about these items. For example, the sleeping cardigan. Yeah. Is it a thing? Let me tell you, because I Googled it. Oh. It is.
So if you type in sleeping cardigan on Google, one of the first things that comes up is a sleep sweater from Target. What? How do you not already know about this? I don't know. Target expert. I know. It said sleeping sweaters. You can get them at Target. Sleeping sweaters.
Well, I shot a movie in Detroit. It was the movie that I fell in love with Lee, giant mechanical man, and it was very cold, and we were staying in this hotel, and I could not get warm, and I wore a sweater to bed and a hat. I was like fully dressed when I went to sleep. Oh, I go to sleep with like three layers on and Josh is in like his undies. Well, it's ridiculous. You clearly need a sleeping cardigan from Target.
I guess I need a sleep sweater is what Target calls it. And then Angela also gets her sleep apnea mask back. Do we find out that Angela has sleep apnea? I mean, this is a serious sleep disorder. Well, we got a fan question from Rachel Nielsen about that. She was very surprised when Dwight handed Angela the CPAP machine. She said, as someone who used to work in the sleep disorder industry, this was very interesting to me because Angela does not fit the typical CPAP profile.
I would have thought Dwight used it. Was there any thought processor backstory for Angela on this, or was this a total surprise? No backstory for me. I think this made the writer's room chuckle, and it went in the script. Well, I feel very worried for Angela knowing now that she hasn't had her sleep apnea machine for a while. I know. this caused me to feel anxious. I don't like thinking that people are without the necessary tools or medicines that they need for any period of time. You know what really bothers me? What? It really bothers me if I'm watching a movie and someone gets even a minor injury and they don't deal with it immediately. It really, I'm very distracted by it. Like someone gets a cut and they don't like wrap it up right. It happens a lot in action films and it really bugs me. But what really is, bothers me is after someone gets an injury when the villain presses on the injury.
You know, like someone gets like a bullet to the shoulder and then when they're being interrogated by the villain, the villain presses on their wound. I can't. It's the hebe-jeebies for me and I can't deal with it. Well, do not watch the show alone where they drop people off in the middle of nowhere and they have to just survive because they get injured and they have to try to patch it up on their own. If it gets really bad, they send a medic in, but it's got to get bad for the medic to like chop her in. No. You couldn't do it.
See, I can't. I couldn't do it. And then you, you know, of course, you're constantly seeing like their banged up thumb as they try to fish. Yeah, this is what I'm saying. I can't. You can't do it. You can't do it.
No. Well, the last thing on the list, of course, is the chair of figurine. And I want you guys to know, I own one. Do you have the one from the show? No, no. It's so funny to me. I was given one as a gift. I don't know when even like in.
high school from like, I don't know, Aunt Brenda, did you give it to me? Anyway, I have a little chair figurine and it went with me to college and sat on my window seal and it made its way all the way to California. And it was on my dresser with like my dresser in the bedroom and I need to go see if it's still there because at some point, Isabel thought it was cute and then Isabel would like, like, I think put it in her room. I'm trying to track it down, guys. Anyway, long boring story to tell you in real life I have a chair of figurine. rain. Also at six minutes and 24 seconds in this scene, Angela, you are wearing very high heels. Why? So high. Oh, probably because I had to stand next to rain because normally in my scenes with him,
he's seated. And if I have to stand next to him, he's six three, I am five one. You get the big heels, get brought out. Well, these were massive. Guys, check it out, six minutes, 24 seconds. And also, if you toggle back to six minutes, nine seconds, there's a, great shot of my cat hair clip that Kim Ferry, who did my hair, made herself with like a glue gun. And years later, she gave it to me in a shadow box and I have my cat hair clips. Aw, I know. So now we're going to move on to the scene where Kevin makes a big announcement to the bullpen that he would really love them to come see his band. It's like a battle of the band's night. And there's going to be an applause meter and he will only win by clapping
and he wants everyone to come and clap for his band, Scrantonicity 2, not Scrantonicity, which he is no longer a part of. There is clearly some bad blood that we don't know about. But he invites the whole office to please come. Well, we had a fan question about this. Okay. From Naomi Y., Beatrice W., M. Raines, Alison Quigley, and Elizabeth Shannon. They said, why didn't Pam go see Kevin's band?
No one came to her art show and she felt so hurt. Wouldn't she want to see Kevin so he wouldn't feel unsupported the way she did? Wow, that's a really good call. Yeah. Here's what I'm thinking, guys. I'm thinking maybe she has gone to see his band. Maybe she went to go see Scranton a city. Maybe everyone in the office has gone to see it.
And this is like another request to come see the band. You know those people, right? Like they're in the pan or they do stand up. And you're like, dude, I've seen seven of your standup shows. Like, I can't come to this one tonight. I just can't do it. Maybe that's what's happening. I think I was this person because I was always in an improv show.
I was always like, hey, catch my improv show. And people are like, you perform three times a week for like the last four years. I can't come see you do improv anymore. Stop asking me. I can relate too because I did all that stuff too. And I know that especially with stand-up, like at least at the level that I was performing. Guys, I didn't do stand-up. I did this really weird comedic magic show.
I won't go down that rabbit hole now. What? Yeah. What? I did. It was like a, I was a silent comedic. magician. What? And I performed to music in comedy clubs. Jenna, this is so amazing. I cannot believe I didn't know this about you. We've been friends for so long. You were like a comedic
mime. Yeah. What? I would give anything to see that. Anything. I did magic tricks using my hands. Oh, God. And they weren't really magic. It was a joke, but I performed it as if I was a great magician. So it was like an ironic kind of like. And you did it to music. To music. And did you speak?
No. No, there was no speaking. Oh, lady. Yeah. I need a photo. I need a video. I need something. Okay.
I'll do the show for you sometime. This was my only foray into. What? Promise me, we will have wine together and you will do this for me. I'll do it. I still have my tuxedo and the music. Yeah, I still have it. You wore a tuxedo.
Yes, I was a fancy magician. I wore a coat and tails. Oh, my God. Yeah. So, listen, my point is, I don't know how to come back from that. I don't know. It's going to take me a beat. Okay, well, listen, what I'm saying in relation to Scrantonicity to,
is in my experience performing this show, the number of people you brought in who bought a ticket to, like, the comedy show that night, that determined your placement in the show. So, like, if no one came, you'd be at the end of the night and you'd be performing to a room of, like, three people. Right. So, you know, this is why Kevin needs people to come, I think,
because, well, he has the applause meter. I don't know. This is gone very off topic, everyone. I'm sorry. I, I, my heart is so full. I am, I am, this is a gift. I was not expecting today. I have all of these visuals in my head of you in a tuxedo,
miming magic tricks at a comedy club. It's, um, yeah. Oh, it's, it's just 100% awesome. Okay. Well, now Michael. Also says he cannot go to Kevin's show. And Jim and Pam, they're like, oh, light bulb. This is when we tell him we should have dinner because they know he's not available.
So sneaky, you two. Yes. Also, very sweet to realize that if Michael was available, he probably would go to Kevin's show because that's Michael, right? Of course. He goes to everything. Yeah. And also, maybe now it's an opportunity to get away from Jan. Yeah.
There's a whole deleted scene runner where he's just avoiding having to talk to her. Well, the reason that Michael can't go to this show or have dinner with Jim and Pam is because he has taken a second job as a telemarketer to pay his bills. And Paul does this very beautiful thing, I think, in his directing, as Michael's riding the bus, getting off the bus stop, walking into this building, you hear this dialogue. And it says, I'm sorry, Mr. O'Brien. I didn't mean to interrupt your dinner. I just have a very exciting offer. My records indicate that you have expressed interest in losing some weight. Well, what if I told you that I have a pill that will make you 50 pounds lighter in five minutes?
How does that sound? Amazing, right? And it's this wonderful way that we now, as an audience, know exactly what's happening. Yeah. Before we even see what's in the building. I thought it was so brilliant. Yeah. Yeah, that's some beautiful writing. Well, now also, Pam and Jim are arriving to Shrewt Farms. Yeah, Pam is clearly in super pun mode. She's calling it the Beats Motel, the Embassy Beats, the Radish Inn. She's in rare form.
Well, this scene of Jim and Pam driving up to Shrewd Farms, this is the scene where John turned on the seat warmer. On my side of the car, we talked about it when he came on office ladies. Yes, he called it his Clooney joke, right? Yes, yes. I just kept getting so hot. I was like, John, I am so hot. Are you hot? He's like, no, I don't know what you're talking about.
And he had turned on my seat warmer. Oh, my gosh. I love that. Because you couldn't have the AC on in the car. That was the thing because it messed with the sound. Right. So we had to have, you know, the car is getting warm. It was warm in the day.
And then on top of it, your seat is heating up. That's so great. Well, I want you guys to know right as they turn down the road to go to Shrewp Farms, when this scene is happening, there's a great shot of the Shrewp Farms mailbox. And the many times that I filmed there with Rain, one time I took my camera and I took all of these kind of artsy photos. And I took an artsy photo of the mailbox. But I love it. I actually think it would be really cool. like I should like blow it up like canvas size. I think it looks really cool.
We had a fan question about this scene of Jim and Pam arriving at Shrewt Farms from Amaya Norsey. She said at around eight minutes, 21 seconds, Moes appears behind their car and starts running alongside them. How was that decided? Because it's really funny and it creates Moses' personality. I reached out to Paul. I would love to hear what he says. Well, first of all, he came up with the idea for Moes running alongside the car while in a cafe in Russia. I love how... It's like his inspiration is in Russia. It's hilarious. I love how he's always in these like foreign countries when he is writing these scripts and having his good ideas.
But he said he started laughing out loud at the idea of Moes running alongside the car, quote, like a dog. And that's what he wrote in the script. So that moment was totally scripted that Moes would run alongside the car like a puppy dog to greet the new visitors. And it was written by an American tourist in Russia laughing out loud by himself
to no one. In a cafe. Well, I wanted to commend Mike Scher on how fast he is. So fast. Dang! And you guys, we filmed that several times. We filmed that arrival because we had to film it with a cameraman inside the car, but then we
also have a shot of us driving where we took the cameraman out of the car and they just shot John and I. So, I mean, Mike ran a lot that day. Well, I think Mike was put through the ringer in this episode. There is a whole deleted scene where he is jumping on a kind of busted trampoline for Pam and Jim and doing all of these things, helicopter, look over here. and he's doing, like, constantly, he was on that trampoline doing tons of stuff. He must have been so sore after this day.
And hot and tired. Yeah. Well, lady, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to meet Nick Figaro, manager to the stars, and also take a look inside Shrewt farms. I like it. All right. I'm going to take a break and I will not be on a yacht, but I might be doing some magic. So now we are back.
Michael is in his cubicle at the telemarketing company, and his boss, Nick Figuero, notices the camera crew. He walks over, he's like, what's happening here? Michael's like, it's okay, they're with me. And then he has this very funny speech where he's like, we're a legitimate operation. Like, clearly they're not. Because he literally not.
He has to, like, point that out. Well, the actor who plays Nick Figuero is Alan Wasserman, and here are some other roles that he has played. He's done a ton of television shows, but I also found it interesting that he played the gym teacher in the Tom Hanks movie Big and the job interviewer in the Tom Cruise movie Cocktails. Oh, wow. Oh, those are two great movies. Well, my favorite thing is when he does what Michael always does. He calls a conference room meeting. Five minutes.
And Mike's like, oh, these things are useless. Yes. And then in this conference room meeting, when Nick Figaro is trying to explain how to make a sale, Michael is just making jokes under his breath. Yes. And his coworkers love him. He's the gym of the telemarketing office. He is.
and they just want him to hang out with him. They're constantly inviting him to go hang out. There's deleted scenes where they are just, they hang on his every word. Well, I got very interested in this scene at 10 minutes, 25 seconds. There is a couple. Did you see them? The woman is pregnant, very pregnant, and this man, they're all over each other, very lovey-dovey, right? And they are in all the,
other deleted scenes too. They're always sort of like in some kind of embrace. I became a little bit obsessed with them. I was like, is this woman really pregnant? Where they hired as a couple? What is the story here? So I did a bit of a deep dive. Okay. I found out that the woman is an actress named Ann Maddox. And then I found out that Ann Maddox is our producer Cody's friend. What? They're friends on Instagram. I deep dived. I was like, how can I get an end with this woman, Anne? So Cody reached out to her friend and she answered all my questions. Oh, give me all of it. I want it. Give it to me. Okay. Here's how it went down. Anne was a performer at UCB and she said that there was a request for female performers to come in for a role in the office. She was not pregnant in real life,
but the role was for a young pregnant woman working nights alongside her baby dad. and it was scripted that this couple would be lovey-dovey and affectionate constantly. So she auditioned, she got the role, and then she got paired with this other actor randomly. But here's what she said. She said, I remember that one of the cameramen did not know that the cuddling was in the script. And he kept saying to me and my co-star, you guys are so affectionate. And then he turned to the other camera operator and said, they've been like this all day. It's so funny. And she was like, no, it was scripted. It was
scripted. She also remembered that they shot in the LA Times building. She remembered that we had amazing food and that the cast and crew were so nice. But she said what's so heartwarming to her about that memory is just how everyone on set treated her like a friend. The crew, the cast, She said she just had the best time of her life and she'll cherish the experience forever. It was so nice. I love that. I also love what a very specific thing that Paul did. Paul was so thoughtful in filling out the world at the telemarketing company that he wrote in the script
that would be a young pregnant woman and her baby daddy. And that was so specific. Yeah. I love that we often did that on the show where even minor characters who show show up for just one episode, they have a story. That's so great. I just love it. Yeah. And there were a lot of deleted scenes. There's a lot of scenes you don't see of this couple and of all these people interacting with Michael. Yes, this couple loved Michael. They invited him out to dinner. There's a deleted scene with it. And once again, Jenna, I feel like our set decorators were having fun because there's
all of these cartoon clippings. So many. So many. And then there's a white piece of paper that says constant, continuous Roger demands. Don't know. Don't know. Very strange. I saw it too. I don't know what it means. Well, Alan Wasserman as Nick Vigero was fantastic.
I thought he was perfect. I loved his whole make the call, say the lines, make the sale. He was just like, I believed him 100% that he was this guy. Well, you know, Ange, in addition to being a silent magician, I always, also worked as a telemarketer. And I can tell you that Ellen Wasserman's performance is right on. He's like every boss I ever had in my telemarketing days. Well, you know, I worked at 1-800 dentist as an operator and I would constantly get in trouble for not saying line number 13 correctly. Oh, yeah. The scripts are very specific. Like they've been researched. They've been put through
focus groups. My job was to call people and get them to subscribe to the St. Louis Post Dispatch newspaper. And we had a big deal on the Sunday paper. And I was supposed to push the Sunday paper. Well, line 13, if I remember, was something about like you would say what their ailment was and tell them the dentist you were going to send them to. And it was so stilted. And I remember I would say like, you know what? It sounds like to me you might need a root canal. I mean, that kind of pain like that sounds like an abscess and literally my manager would come in waving his arms and you'd be like you are not a dental professional you cannot diagnose yeah have to say this line exactly well let me help you with that toothache by finding a dentist for you in your area like i can't
say sounds like a root canal to me what are you doing lady so i would get in trouble well jennah should we get to shrewp farms. Let's go to shrewd farms. Jim and Pam are sitting on a couch in what looks like a sort of reception slash lobby area. And Dwight is explaining that there are three types of rooms available. He's checking them in. They can stay in America, irrigation, or nighttime. Pam immediately says irrigation. I mean, without thought, she was so positive. Yeah. I'm curious about nighttime, but I think I would have also chosen irrigation. And by the way, it doesn't disappoint. When Dwight shows them to their room, the irrigation room has a lot of pipes hanging from the walls.
It's a wonderful design. Pipes with no purpose, though. No, no, no. It's decor. They're decorative, yeah. Decorative pipes. Yes. And two twin beds.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Now, I believe, I don't know if there's a deleted scene of it, but there was a scene that we shot where you see that Jim and Pam have pushed the two beds together. In the morning, you see into the room and Jim and Pam have actually made it one bed. Yes. And I was like, wait, is there two beds or one bed? And then I realized what they had done. Yes.
Yes. But I really like this moment on the two beds with Jim and Pam. when Jim says one and six. And Pam's like, what? And he's like, oh, I'm sorry. I thought you asked me, what are our chances of being murdered tonight? Yeah.
And Jim has this really sweet talking head where he says he had this whole vision of what it would be like to have a weekend away with Pam. What our first trip away would be like? It's so romantic, really, and sweet. And he said it definitely would not have been, you know, wine made out of beats.
Probably not with Dwight and definitely not with so much manure. Yeah, maybe some manure. But less, less manure. Yeah, and we filmed all of these little moments that went under this talking head. So you see Dwight mashing up beats to make beet wine and then you see us out in the field helping to shovel this manure. And then Moes gets into a manure like a snowball fight with Dwight. but he's throwing manure. Mm-hmm.
And I remember shooting all of that. We had a fan question from Matthew K. When Dwight and Pam are shoveling manure, was it real? And was the moment when Moe starts throwing manure at Dwight scripted, or was that just Mike Scher messing with rain? Okay, it was not real manure. Right. It was not.
Of course not. Yeah. No. Faking manure. Put it on our list. Yes. And it was scripted, this idea. this little snowball fight of manure.
That was in the script. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. So, yeah, faky poo. I wonder what it was made of. It was just like dirt and there was some, you know, hay inside of it and stuff. It was just like a muddy kind of mess. Right.
So they probably could really pelt each other. It probably could hurt. Yes. Lady, I want to point something out about this episode. And this scene here when we're shoveling the manure is really your best. look at it. Here is my thing. What the F am I wearing? I know. Did you look at my outfit in this episode? What is it? My pants look waterproof. Well, also they don't fit. They're too long. They're all baggy. They like go over your shoes. They look like a pair of very like hip-hugger
waterproof cargo pants. I don't know. And a very, very ill-fitted sweater. I know. I know. Oh, and also, like, did we not alter anything? Did Pam not want to look cute on her first night away with Jim? Pam. Well, I think you look very cute later in your gray tank top, though. You look very cute. I do look really cute in my great tank top. You do. When it's time for bed.
I was like, oh, Jenna looks so cute. But this outfit is a hot mess. It really, really is. Well, you mentioned my little tank top, Angela. and first of all, I don't sleep in clothes like that. I sleep completely dressed. Lee calls it my sleeping suit. He's like, it's amazing how you've covered up all of your skin from your neck down to your wrists, down to your ankles.
Because I get cold at night, we've discussed. But Pam is in the cutest little tank top and pajama pants. It was freezing in that building. But it's a really cute moment. because Dwight is reading them a bedtime story. He's reading them Harry Potter. And Jim and Pam are snuggling and Moses
listening. It's sweet and awkward all at the same time. Well, we had a fan question. A lot of fan questions about the Harry Potter book. Was he really reading? Yada yada. Well, Emma H has come to our rescue
and she says, I am currently rereading the Harry Potter series and I just happened to come across the page that Dwight reads to Jim and Pam. It is page 85 from the Deathly Hollow's book. It is the scene when Voldemar is interrogating Olavander and the Wandmaker. Now, I'm sorry if I stumbled through that,
but I am not familiar with this series. This falls into the Star Wars area for me. Okay, Jenna. Okay. Well, did I say those names right, Voldemort? Voldemort. Isn't that the person you're not supposed to say? Yes, exactly.
and olivander well that is fantastic i love to know where that is in the book so thanks for that catch emma and before we move away from this lovely harry potter reading jenna here's my thing about pam's outfit what pam is doing what you do at the beginning of a relationship where you're still trying to look cute at bedtime that will pass maybe that's what she really sleeps in I need to know this, actually. Whenever I watch TV shows or movies and women are in the morning, they're getting coffee in the morning or they're going to bed at night, they're always dressed in these like little pajamas with the little shorts and the little tank tops or something. I don't know. Sometimes women are wearing like, what are those things?
like silken shift dress things to bed. Laundre? Laundere? Not full lingerie, but like a, you know, what are they called? They're like silk or satin. What are they called? I don't know, but I used to have little tank top and short combos. I would get them at Target, like pajamas.
And in the summer, I would sleep in shorts. I mean, because you know, I'm always going to have my place nice and warm. Sam just wrote, a slip? Yeah, like a slip dress thing. Yes, like a silky, slippy dress pajama thing. Who sleeps in that? Anyone out there, literally any woman listening, have you ever slept in one of those
when you weren't trying to impress a man? Oh, yeah. Like, this is what I love to sleep in. This is my go-to. I love to sleep in a silk slip. Yeah. Neglishe? A negligee.
That's it. A negligee. Who sleeps in a negligee for reals? Well, there was a time in my life. I would have slept in a tank top in shorts. But now I live with a mountain man who freezes me out. And I'm sorry, those days are gone. I'm fully, I'm in my sleep suit, Jenna.
All right. Well, so everybody is winding down for the night at Shrewt Farms. Michael is still at work. He's still telemarketing. But it's time for his dinner break. Yes, it's dinner time. And his cubicle mate right next to him is Vickram. Vikram is played by Ranjit Chaudhry.
He does such a phenomenal job. I thought it was perfect. Everything he said as an actor, he just sort of threw it away, you know? And I just thought he was a phenomenal actor, and I just thought he crushed all of his scenes. It was so believable. Vickram is eating mixed masala and eggplant and rice. His dinner looks amazing, and it looks like it was prepared with love and all these little nice containers. And Michael is having a vanilla crisp bar.
Yes. which is a real thing. It's a power bar. Yeah. Yeah. But what you see is that, you know, well, Jan doesn't know where Michael is, but she certainly hasn't sent him to work with a lovely meal, the way Vickram's partner clearly has. Ranji, very sadly, he passed away in April of last year. He was so great to work with. And guys, he's going to come back for another episode. You might remember he is part of Michael's dream team when Michael starts the Michael Scott Paper Company. So, I got to work with him when he came back. And I got a few facts on him because I just thought he was so wonderful.
You know, his mother was a theater teacher and an actress. His stepfather was a theater director. And he just, he worked his whole life as an actor and a writer. And he just had this very long career as an artist and comes from a long line of artists. So he's just amazing. I loved watching him in his scene. I agree. Well, after they have dinner, Michael is sort of holding court with the other telemarketers. They love him. He's talking about Die Hard and how Die Hard won the original.
John McLean was just this normal guy. You know, he's just a New York City cop and then he gets his feet cut and gets beat up. Jenna, I had just watched Die Hard over the holidays. We were picking Christmas movies and it's a kind of a great Christmas movie. It's one of my favorite Christmas movies. And right out of the gate, Josh turns to me and goes, I would have put my shoes on. The minute I heard gunfire, I would have put my shoes on. This was a really hard thing for Josh to get past that this guy had no shoes on for like the whole movie. And also, also he takes the shoes off this enormously tall Nordic guy, right? He's just died. Massive dude. And he's like, shoes are too small. And we're like, okay, we're going to call BS on that. There's no way
that dude's feet are smaller than yours, Bruce Willis. What's happening? Yeah. Well, you know, and then the thing happens in this movie that's real hard for me, where he gets the piece of glass and his foot and he does not take care of that properly. He just does not. No. But it's such a...
I mean, I know he doesn't have a lot of options, but that kind of stuff. It just, ooh. It gets you. Well, anyway, everyone is loving Michael's theory on Die Hard and the Die Hard series. And one of the co-workers is like, dude, you should review movies. They're like, yeah. And then Michael's like, actually, I'm writing a movie. Yeah, threat level midnight.
Yeah. And they're like, oh. Ooh. But I just think it's so incredibly charming that Michael is like, he's the cool dude. I know. He's the cool dude at this place. I know. Well, back at Shrewp Farms, Pam hears a very strange knocking noise.
she decides to investigate. And it's Moes in an outhouse, an outhouse, and the wind is blowing the door, whack, whack, whack. And Pam is like, what sentry is this? I know. Well, Paul told me this is one of his favorite shots from this episode because it's all one long tracking shot and they had to time it out.
They had to, you know, rack focus from Pam out to the outhouse. And, oh, poor Mike Schur had to. just sit out there and just wait for us every time we would reset. I mean, again, he's like put through the ringer in this episode. You know it was cold out there? Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Now, I want to point out, in an earlier episode,
when Dwight is telling us about Shrewp Farms, he says that there's only one bathroom and it's under the porch. Oh, nice catch. So I like to think that maybe when he decided to do the B&B, he upgraded to an outhouse. A proper outhouse. Yes, this is my backstory for the Shrew Farm's outhouse. So they figure out what that sound is. So now Jim and Pam are going to go back to bed.
But now there's like a wailing, like a moaning. Yes. I mean, it's like, what is that noise? And so Jim, it's like his turn. So he's going to check it out. Well, at 15 minutes, 40 seconds, he approaches a door. Did you notice the wooden plaque says private room? Yes.
Right? Yes. And he goes in and Dwight is holding the chair of figurine and moaning, but very briefly, and I'm talking very briefly, at 15 minutes, 52 seconds, over Jim's shoulder, you can see a little bit of a poster and I zoomed in on this poster and the legs it looks like a rock and roll band and the legs of the pants are white with gray stripes like skin tight pants you can't really make out the face but I got obsessed with these pants and I started looking up every Motley crew poster I could find because I'm positive it's Montley Crew right it's Dwight okay it's got to be
motley crew. I'm telling you it is. I found a photo of Tommy Lee in the same white skin-tight stripy pants. And there is no doubt in my mind that in the private room, the love sanctuary of Angela and Dwight, that there's a Motley crew poster. If you remember on their album, Decade of Decadence, 81, there's a song called Angela. It's going to come into play later. Sam, hit it. And when the storms, scream, Angela, Angela, I'll be there. Wow. Yeah, that poster of Montley Crew, you know what that means to Dwight. It's his lady.
It's his heavy metal. And fans that have watched the show all the way through. I don't want to do any spoilers. That song's going to come back in a big way later. Wow. Wow. Well, I'll tell you what I noticed in this scene. At 16 minutes, we have got a huge,
duh white from Jim. But then at the end of the scene, when he's leaving the room, he throws out a regular Dwight. No. We have a duh white and a Dwight in the same scene. He never said Dwight. He always said DeWite.
Is this the one time John says Dwight? Well, I listened to it several times. Oh, my gosh, because this is our job. You're listening to that over and over. Meanwhile, I'm Google searching, like, rock and roll band pants. Well, I think he says Dwight, like Dwight, but it's the closest thing to a Dwight we're going to get. Okay. Well, guys, before we finish up here, we've got one last scene.
it's the end of Michael's work day and he's walking outside everyone's inviting him to come to the bar with him come on Michael we want to spend more time with you yeah but he can't yeah Jan has come to pick him up she gets out of the car and she says you drive I've had too much wine great glad you drove here yeah thought the same thing and then Michael's like how was yoga she's like I didn't go. And he's like, why? And she's like, I just didn't. Oh. Oh. So sad. The Jan spiral man. And she's going to take Michael down with her. Yeah. And then Vickram tells Michael, listen, man, you might be able to nab that bonus if you just work a little harder. Vickram gives a, you know, a little pep talk there at the end. He's like, just stick to the script. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, Michael. Well, I love this.
episode. I love breaking down this first part. I can't wait to get to the next part. And thank you so much everyone for sending in your questions. And I, we just, Jen and I just freaking love doing this. We just love it. We love it. All right. Well, we will see you next week for Money Part 2. Money Part 2. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.